it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes hoot-hoot were miles at hashtag
Allen ation what's going on guys welcome
to movie fights it is on and is
happening again we're gonna throw down
in the squared circle of movie Kombat
and oh we've got some three good friends
who are about to turn heel enemies etc
on each other yeah heels and baby faces
I'm pandemonium babe right now yes okay
that was kabob a wrestling listen to
tights and fight poster by Daniel
Radford and how lovely okay fighting
today first he is the head writer of
honest trailers and he's the most
finicky eater here at movie fight oh
wait a minute Sarah Gilbert don't
slander my good name I will eat anything
but good to be here good to have you sir
thank you for stepping into the ring oh
this very hilarious gentleman also
writes honest trailers you see on sju
and all-around swell guy the most well
quaffed gentleman for sure big time in
the halls of screen junkies Joestar hi
very excited to do this show today it's
like a crashing wave can someone
Photoshop a little surfer on top I
actually I get hired sometimes it's a
Craigslist gig I just sit in therapy
offices and people just they like do
like blue noise or whatever you've got a
service you know this gentleman as the
professor he's taken off the mortarboard
and he stepped into the ring welcome to
the party lawn Harris thank you didn't
mention my beautiful head of hair
the longest hair drifting back slowly
over Billy business as long as hair to
Billy's got very much relying on the
hair length Billy biz haircut watch 2018
o thing okay T bring up that graphic mom
thanks for being here so deciding these
shenanigans are gonna be myself and the
Dan's the Dan cam what's up Dan Moreau I
know I I am the finicky eater oh you are
okay by far by gotcha easily when I was
a little kid my mom used to read me a
book about a little boy who loved cheese
peas and chocolate pudding and that was
it does that kind of describe your diet
oh yeah thank you for sharing that with
us Dan of course and the delightful
Danielle Radford Wow
hey Danielle so Dan and I will be voting
on each argument picking our winners and
you will be the voice of the people do
you want to let them know how that works
so the way that this is gonna work is
that in case of a tie then it goes and
gets thrown to us the voice of the
people me and you
so there gonna be a lot of polls going
up on Twitter please join those those
are super fun join the conversation on
hashtag movie fights live however the
only poll that counts for the sake of
the fight is going to be the one on
YouTube and if you're curious about how
that works click down a description to
look below it you can feel free to ask
anybody in the chat we will all be in
there kind of hanging out it's usually
gonna involve some variation of
switching annotations on and off and
we'll let you know when the poll goes
live but it's not gonna go live until
everyone's at least given their initial
argument because it's about the
arguments it's not necessarily about
like what movie if that makes sense
but yeah and also please tweet us things
tweet me
corgis and cats and memes and definitely
like alternate answers a lot of people
send really cool threads please do that
because I try to shout out as much as I
can while we're doing the show
hell yeah and I know owl nation is going
to be tweeting mad owls
screech owls owls barn owl you really
have to watch every week to catch
everything easy to drop that's what our
viewers are called we all know that
hashtag yes
Danielle thank you for that so again
it's a best-of-seven point total game
the first person to four points wins
there are three regular round questions
there were you having that speed round
someone can be down 3-0 going in the
speed round but they can come back up
that from that speed round and overtake
a 3o deficit so at one point you
shouldn't be zero and then time I can
send you into the speed round with a
zero what happens if someone scores nine
points
oh then we've judged the game
incorrectly all right I think that's
about it JT II dropped that sick-ass
package prepared I know using chicken
[Music]
time
Thank You Thor okay so just ignore all
those other movie characters can go
peddle their papers so it's been a fine
summer movie wise but we're not gonna
talk about the fine movies we're gonna
talk about the crap summer is wrapping
up what was the worst movie of the
summer question number one what was the
worst film of the summer
all right gentlemen I hope you picked
out your stinkers favorite Don Henley
song let's do it the boys okay we're
gonna start with player number one
Spencer all right guys well look I
learned something this summer to be a
man you got to be a man and to be a man
you got to be a man about respect and to
be about respect you got to give respect
and have respect and also be a man and
I'm quoting almost verbatim Gotti oh my
god I can't describe it look at that
face that has my face John Travolta
wears the entire movie the entire time
he's doing a bad bad mobster impression
along with every single other character
in this film of whose names I can't
remember they were all like Sid the
trout and Frank also the trout was just
these cookie cutter mobster characters
you could not have done a more generic
movie if you chopped up Godfather parts
1 2 & 3 and Goodfellas and a little bit
of Bronx Tale and put it in a blender
and then just stuck it back on the back
on a cork board this was just absolute
garbage beginning to end I have more to
say but that is the gist
all right movie pass favourite Gotti is
Spencer's choice Joe you know somebody
did make a worst movie by taking a bunch
of just crappy sci-fi tropes and things
you would expect and chopping them up
and sticking them on a cork board and
that movie was called solo ouch Oh hot
solo takes
solo night hey guys would it shock you
if I told you that this movie was very
terrible solo is a disaster on so many
levels it was even if you take the Star
Wars IP out of it it is just a bland
confusing flat movie that doesn't have
anything to say that doesn't really go
in any interesting directions it doesn't
really take any fun twists or turns but
then when you put the Star Wars IP back
into it it's even more depressing
because it's really hard to to make just
a terrible boring disappointing Star
Wars movie it's so hard to take the
magic right at it right out of Star Wars
and that that's what solo really really
managed to do more than any thing that's
come out Star Wars related in the recent
years Solo was the stamp that was just
like I don't know this is just sort of a
boring corporate assembly line now solo
that was a bad film all right so from
Joestar long
so let's start by talking about another
movie that we was not from this summer
that we sort of all universally agreed
on was very bad and that's the lost
world Jurassic Park so the makers of the
new Jurassic world movie decided let's
go back to this movie that no one really
likes that's considered a blight on
Spielberg's entire filmography and let's
remake that one let's let's let's spend
all of our budget to recreate this movie
that already didn't work the first time
and then as an added benefit sort of a
twist at the end let's set the rest of
it in a house now of all the things you
could do with a huge budget summer
Jurassic Park sequel the idea of let's
take all of these dinosaurs let's take
all of this action and let's reset it in
the basement of Downton Abbey would
probably not be yeah that's exactly what
we've done and they've continued on the
trend of each new sequel has to be about
inventing even more dinosaur species as
if that's the thing like like kids
didn't love like the action and the
funny characters and like seeing all
these huge dinosaurs on the big screen
they really loved the talk about
Jeannette
and the science of cloning let's zero in
on bioethical issues as the heart of
this franchise rather than you know like
dinosaurs running around having fun
let's keep the dinosaurs locked up in
cages and zap them with cattle prods and
spend the entire time talking about the
ethics of you know like CRISPR gene
editing programs like that's really what
Jurassic world 2 was about and the one
last thing I'd like to say about how
horrible fallen Kingdom was is that the
the original movie Jurassic Park people
remember for the great effects for you
know all those sort of screen magic that
Spielberg brings but why the movie is so
beloved and has been so remembered are
the characters that's why they kept
trying to bring these characters back
and all the subsequent sequels they do
it in Jurassic world two fallen Kingdom
as well they try to break in Malcolm
back but you can tell they've lost the
music they've lost the sense for what
made these people charismatic Jurassic
world 2 is just filled with the most
generic cookie cutter flat uninteresting
people Bryce Dallas Howard has changed
her entire character from the first film
and nobody's even called attention to it
it's just a complete void of anything
that's interesting it's purely effects
and nothing else and that's why the
worst movie this summer was Jurassic
world 2 fallen Kingdom yeah these guys
didn't like those movies find it out
there are good movies uh you know the
dinosaurs were in down Nabby but that's
at least not another island or a park
you know where han Solo was in solo the
Millennium Falcon or next to a wookie or
in a cantina change the names doesn't
mean he's doing new things he was flying
in space with some asteroids we've seen
the Star Wars movies they're always
gonna be flying in space having battles
Noah's gonna be like invading colonies
around there I'll even throw it in with
the prequels and in six in eight star
wars movies yeah some of the stuff feels
familiar but they're not just straight
up repeating tired beats and looking at
the camera and saying please like us
believe in the console in the Empire
going to war in this movie like that's
the thing we've never seen before any
luck on the ground with all of the
troops like world war
a little bored and I'd like to say
something about John Gotti talk about
John Travolta's incredible performance
do you guys know when the movie Gotti is
set it's in the 1970s if you like to
know who appears multiple times on the
soundtrack for the film Gotti its mr.
worldwide pitbull I mean there are
multiple full songs in this 1970s mob
period so mr. worldwide just refers to
him being from all around the world
it's his control over space and time
problem with that guardians of the
galaxy is set modern-day in another
galaxy and they they use mr. blue sky a
different galaxy let me assure a slight
correction there are pitbull songs that
appeared during the 70's in gotti but
there are also multiple timelines in
kotti gaudy begins and ends in the same
way the Ian Malcolm bookends a fallen
Kingdom with the ghost of John Gotti
here staring out over the New York
skyline saying would you look at that
it's the most beautiful city in the
world
flashes back to John Gotti in prison
with his son John Gotti junior Andy then
flashes back into the 70s there is a
three-layer inception deep time line
going on in the John Gotti movie all I'm
hearing a Spenser compared Gotti to an
excellent movie Inception this is the
interaction of movies you're almost
respecting as solo is just just a pile
of sad the solo Disney makes the misstep
of trying to build out their Star Wars
Expanded Universe with a BVS trick of an
email Darth Maul sends a lady an email
at the end that's her like a character
people have wanted to see since
literally the nineties in fan of
medicine your guys's I feel kind of
similarly about both your movies they're
trafficking on nostalgia they're
coasting off of better films that came
before but they're inoffensive they're
visually effects driven there they're
trading on the past and there's a little
bit for whatever little drops of
nostalgia they can wring out of it
that's fine Gotti is aggressively bad
Gotti is offensive God he is so
incompetently shot it looks like it was
filmed by one of the guys from Entourage
because that's who from Entourage
directed God are you really saying that
Gaudi is like a personal statement from
new filmmakers who are trying to like
get their voice out there whereas either
book it on soulless corporate out but
like who do you rather see something
personal that means something to the
filmmaker command if you rather than
Solis Rana Talk technical filmmaking
solo is the colour Brown from start to
finish it is just there's just a brown
filter over the whole thing
the production design was cool solo the
car heist was fine see it was just the
colors were just flat and mute and just
and just said look it was hidden there's
a sort of look and feel of so like
the other thing I have to say buddy like
the effects are terrible does not look
at its trying for this sort of like
hyper saturated use of colors but when
it's doing the lava effects in
particular it looks like somebody
spilled chunky salsa on the print and
Umbridge Sur of what had the way you
characterized fallen kingdom is taking
place in a house I don't blame you for
sleeping through the whole first half of
the movie but the first half of the
movie takes place on dinosaur volcano
island lost world like we got a rand up
these dinosaurs because we're gonna sell
them later and then you get like a
bizarre like auction see where people
are bidding like three million dollars
on a dinosaur that you can shoot a laser
your people doing those felis or a
dinosaur that was a smart way to set up
your spin-offs much more smarter than
solo did it now we can see a sequel
where what did that executive from
Google do just get Lucy's riders prequel
and we're all gonna be happy for it all
right
let's bring it to a close with some
final thoughts will start with Spencer
Gatti's the worst mob movie ever made by
far it's not the worst movie of the
summer it's worse than but it is I mean
sorry it's the worst movie of the summer
it's nothing is the worst mob movie ever
made worse than Godfather 3 worse than
the what's another bad mob movie lon you
know everything black black mass sure
wait where's the black whites worse than
gangster squad this is an absolute
travesty you could replace every
character in Gotti with Fat Tony from
The Simpsons and it wouldn't make a
single difference it makes me excited
pitbull songs it's visually incoherent
the music is bad it's a bad there's a
non-existent story it's basically a
visual retelling of John Gotti's
Wikipedia page and then it ends with
ghost Gotti saying New York it's the
worst thing I saw this number by far all
right Thank You Spencer Joestar I think
for sad a movie as it was I think
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom at least
did some basic things correctly there
was some good you know tension building
in the sequence where they're in the
dark
weird little Museum in Downton Abbey I'm
just gonna keep calling it Downton Abbey
from now on thank you it is Downton
Abbey I think at its core it's it's it's
a shallow movie but it's competently
done and you can walk out of it and go
saw a brontosaurus sadly roar well lava
fell on it and I maybe that made me feel
something solo solo is um you know that
fake nerd that the internet made up like
oh you're fake nerd solo is the fake
nerd solo is someone who doesn't know
anything about star wars of the IP that
it's trying to tell a story around
trying to trying to tell that story it
just falls on its face on every every
level it tries to give you these
emotional connections that don't work to
things that you didn't even need
connected you know I don't need to see
how Chewie and Han you know met and fell
in love but the fact that they show it
and it still doesn't give me any more
new emotional appreciation to their
relationship I think it said and as for
Gotti I think something that is
important in the movie watching
experience is rewatch ability and I
don't want to sell you out buddy but
today we share we all share a room
together and Spencer said this sentence
and it just stuck in my head I got to
watch Gotti again yeah to prepare for
the fight no no you were excited about
the prospect of watching yottabytes of
watching body and I think that enjoy
showing us Gotti
well I move it are we really full and
pulling back the curtain
since watched a bunch of God so in
fairness all right Joe I'm not I just
want to talk about Logan and David
Tennant that's all their lives are now
thank you Joestar lon Harris final
thoughts so just to talk about a little
bit more about sort of the utter failure
of Jurassic world to capture it doesn't
capture anything that the Jurassic Park
franchise especially the first movie is
about which is the Wonder and and
spectacular miss and awesomeness of
seeing dinosaurs and then the terror of
characters that you care about being
chased around by dinosaurs and it
doesn't capture either of those motions
at all it's really just sort of a
we tread let's do another horror movie
with Dinosaurs where they pop out at
people and everybody gets scared and
runs away it's really just coasting on
that over and over again
Joe's main comment was that solo made
him really sad and then the one scene
that he picked up from my movie was a
brontosaurus literally being burned
alive and howling in pain as people
watch like that's not the majesty of
dinosaurs the people loved from Jurassic
Park that's not the terror of being
chased around by a realistic Tyler
that's just a dinosaur burning to death
and screaming like that's why would
anyone want to watch that
the last thing I want to say about Gaudi
is that without God if the film had not
been released we would not know any of
the things that we discovered about
tomatoes being manipulated
Thank You lon thank you gentlemen dan
Merle any any any facts to correct
anything - no facts to correct other
than that Joe used the phrase much more
smarter and I think at one point
referred to eight Star Wars movies
that's admissible in the sense of like
eight episodic ones ten if you include
robot and solo 11 if you include the
Clone Wars but I'll let that one scare
amount of courage 13 - rock adventures
and of a sudden play I do count Ewok
adventures I don't count rogue one
not canon okay wow you guys all made
strong arguments as to why your film I
didn't enjoy it why your film might be
the worst why your film was not good and
other synonyms you know what Joe I feel
you on Star Wars but I you made on solo
but you made it seem to me you made more
of an argument for solo being mad and
wanting to go into Star Wars movies
looking for magic and you got mad
instead of magic and I feel like it
wasn't quite the worst but you
competently listed why solo was not a
spectacular Star Wars offering so I
really liked your argument but I feel
like these two made better arguments as
to why theirs was the worst and man
Spencer I was I was really feeling it
but then I started to feel that it might
be a fun hate watch like a fun enjoyable
watch and learn to walk yeah and lon you
you listed so much stuff like brights
Bryce Dallas Howard is character
changing it being a blood like bringing
up the blight on Spielberg's career but
at the end of the day I think Spencer
sold it the bestest
yeah I mean because and I felt like it
what might have been my editorializing
that made it a like a fun hate watch and
in like an inadvertent kind of happening
style come you're a man of respect and I
respect that
ya know you hid the dialogue you have to
acting you at the construction of the
film I feel like your argument was the
most overwhelming I go with Spencer and
ngati dan i am going to disregard long's
transparent success to me in this
closing are you call me dan through
hearsay it's what i love about this game
is it's a game of arguments and
counter-arguments and everyone i think
did really really well on their
arguments I think everyone laid out very
compelling cases for all of their
respective choices so to me my attention
then went to the counter-arguments and I
felt like every time it came down to a
counter argument it gets gaudy
there was deflection Spencer brings up
the crowd to like it's just a new
filmmaker and then he brings up the fact
that it had no framing device whatsoever
the made sense it like sounds like
you're making it sound like inception
and they didn't engage like you have to
engage encounter you can't deflect or
try to cast blame away from the fact
that you can't argue against the point
and every time Spencer brought up a
point I felt like those two guys both
deflected it and tried to make a joke
out of it and I'm gone with Spencer
because I felt like they didn't have an
answer for his arguments so they just
wanted to make jokes so I respect that I
respect that then it's one of your
strategies that you invented yes Spencer
Gilbert he's a finicky eater everybody
got that
Danielle Olivia all things are pretty
overwhelming 71% forgot 60% Jurassic
world fallen kingdom 11% solo a Star
Wars story some other things people were
bringing up a lot of people saying the
Meg was not great a lot of votes from
mile 22 a lot of people mentioning
Slender Man and on Twitter we have at
the Matt Blair who is one of two people
who submitted Joestar with a surfer on
his head one being at later limbs with a
Z so go check those they will creep it
on on the Instagram and I appreciate it
okay bonus points for them if it's
either Patrick Swayze or world's
greatest surfer Kelly Slater
like a surf talk okay so we're going
into research battles that we're going
back to round two spending is up one to
nil for the other fellows one round so
far yes there's only one cause this
one's mine all right bless joestar
question numero dos so Danny Boyle's out
who should direct the new bond who
should direct the new bond now that
Danny Boyle is out and it's question
number two we'll start with player
number two mr. Joestar you know what I'm
fine Danny Boyle's not doing James Bond
I think he was gonna make another James
Bond movie we've seen pretty much the
same Daniel Craig James Bond over and
over again now the Pierce Brosnan's all
sort of felt the same really with any
director for James Bond you're just
gonna say how campy or serious is it
gonna be and that's as once we have the
the you know where that falls on the
scale determined then you sort of know
what movie you're gonna get so I want to
go a different direction with James Bond
and I want Wes Anderson to direct it
look at that quirky little son of a
[ __ ] I want a perfectly symmetrical
Alec Baldwin narrated James Bond movie
where he late where Q lays out all his
gadgets and we get single inserts of all
of them in future pot sliding in the
frame I want after he he has sex with
anjelica huston
for us to see anjelica huston hand write
him a letter about the date that they
just went on and how it was enjoyable
and then as she puts it into the post
she's just dancing to a record player
that is I just want something new from
the Bond franchise and I feel like the
only director that can actually give us
a bond that we haven't seen yet is Wes
Anderson Oh fancy boy Wes it potentially
twee James Bond
thank you Joe long now usually on movie
fights I don't go for the most obvious
answer and the pest I've been repeatedly
smacked down for this so in this case I
wanted to go with the most obvious
correct answer and I think that after
the to last Mission Impossible films
he's made the correct answer is
Christopher McQuarrie he's shown that he
can make films that are very much in
line with what the James Bond franchise
is like but are not the James Bond
franchise which leaves it open and it
would be interesting to see him get a
crack at sort of the granddaddy of all
espionage franchises the Bond films we
know that he can do literally everything
that make Bond films great the action
set-pieces are gonna be great the stunt
sequences are gonna be great we're gonna
have a good compelling female lead that
really holds her own against James Bond
we're gonna have a great nemesis that's
a real good match for James Bond and the
great thing about christopher mcquarrie
too is that he's writing these scripts
we know that he can conceptualize these
stories I think he's done besides the
mission of possible foes he did Jack
Reacher which is a really effective
kick-ass action movie he did way of the
gun which is a really low budget movie
that still works great as an action film
and he wrote some great movies chill I
mean he wrote usual suspects like he
knows his way around these kind of
twisty intricate plots don't get too
caught up in the plotting that are good
sort of launching pads for these fun
globe-trotting action heavy adventures
the last thing I'd say is that he's made
his last three films with Tom Cruise we
we know that he can get along with
finicky talent that's sort of rumored to
be kind of difficult on set and that's
exactly what you need from a James Bond
director because you're working with
these actors who are contracted for four
or five movies they're all producers
they all want to have a role in sort of
determining what the movie is going to
be like a lot of Bond directors in the
past have really clashed with their
actors and that's what's created a lot
of this sort of subpar Bond movies we've
seen over the years but I think the
queries a guy who could come in you
would really gel with whoever the Bond
actor is gonna be and they're gonna put
together some amazing kick-ass action
scenes that everybody's gonna want to
see all right thank you lon Spencer I
picked a well he's not really
up-and-coming I mean the guys he's made
three movies two of them have been
nominated for Best Picture but he is
young he would be some fresh blood into
the James Bond franchise epic Damien
Chazelle of whiplash and la-la-land and
the what's the one coming out first man
I think that with all the emergence of
all the other spy franchises with your
borns and your kings mins and your
mission
suppose he'd had two we've all had to
think about what really makes a James
Bond movie great what sets him apart
from the other spy franchises and for me
its style its style it's that it's
stylish it's that it's an aesthetic
thing more than it is a heart or a
character or a plot thing and damn if
Damien Chazelle movies aren't stylish
like I didn't love lala land but damn it
looked cool and whiplash looks amazing
and first man is like his first foray in
a kind of an action it's not thriller
but in like an action movie but early
reviews are and they say it looks it
makes Apollo 13 look like you know grade
school so I'm really excited for what
this guy can do I'm really I think he's
a perfect fit for the franchise whoa
three very different answers I like it
fight it out so it's going to be two
James Bond movies where they just like
to sit at home and listen to jazz and
then I've got an actual action thriller
that's gonna span the whole globe you
only see two of those movies you don't
like one of them style is a better fit
for James Bond than it is for made that
piano that weird piano movie would that
would actually fits better in the James
Bond movie and we're had a lot of guys
playing a piece and if he makes one
wrong notice snipers gonna shoot him in
the head that's a James Bond set piece
for us like phone booth he wrote it yes
lon made a really great opening
statement that I thought was really well
thought out to say that he wants to
watch the exact same James Bond movie
that has already been made several times
but also make it just like the Mission
Impossible movie he's already seen
several times I mean you're not gonna
make it one clean fresh James Bond oh
you're gonna make it into Mission
Impossible right now they're different
well sort of small movies already are
kind of inspired by classic you are not
classic James why bees they're still
very different why go to just well it's
either gonna be grittier or slightly
campy er it's gonna be some level of
action just by the way do something fun
do something that's kind of a throwback
yes greedy than the other ones it's not
gonna get Mission Impossible action in a
Bond movie with Daniels pregnant because
he's not insane like Tom Cruise he's not
gonna strap himself to the helicopter he
barely wants to be James Bond he's not
gonna work as his body in the shell of
attention oh this is a great example of
why this movie would be different
because a lot of the tension of the
Mission Impossible movies are be like
this is really Tom Cruise in the middle
yes that's not why I like them that's
not true he's he's doing a great job of
filming these actions he's even when
Cruise isn't doing sounds like way the
gun has great action sequences a Tom
Curren is a minute and it's not like
it's like Benicio del Toro is out there
jumping off yeah but those were global
hits like the reason you want to see
mission positive these days what is Tom
Cruise gonna jump up this time and
obviously there are great action movies
that don't require the lead actor to
also be a stuntman it's not like
Christopher Cooper he's not capable of
doing that it's just different and
that's a great example talking about
who's capable of working with a stuntman
at this point lon just wants to see the
same movie and over and over again I
think it's a silly answer but look I
think what Sanderson has is that his
best when he's pushing himself out of
his comfort zone a little bit that's why
I think fantastic mr. Fox is one of his
best films is because he took that push
into into animation that's why I think
life aquatic is so good because Bill
Murray like really pushed him into the
deep end of like no I want to make a
straight-up comedy and it's really
pushed him out of his comfort zone
that's why I think the guy could
actually make a really fun and
interesting throwback vibe feeling to
the old days the old Connery days
Harrison's latest up but that the Wes
Anderson out of his comfort zone is like
Wes Anderson with a sillier hat on like
it's still a Wes Anderson movie the
movie you described of Angelica has to
dancing to a record player and which I
love I love movies but I personally at
this point with how like how many of the
Daniel Craig Bond movies have actually
been good one of them at this point if
you're like that didn't feel like a
James Bond much at all I'd see boss I
see it as a good thing like thank god
there's a movie and you're turning it
into Mission Impossible at least mine
brings something different to the table
give me a Jeff Goldblum is bond and a
Bill Murray
hello field that's amazing I want to see
that movie here just your board with
bond you don't wanna see bond you see a
film every day on sju we talk about this
weird ass Joker movie and the other day
we were like I'm actually getting
excited about this because it sounds
bonkers and it sounds insane and it's
having something sound bonkers it sounds
like a Wes Anderson movie it just sounds
like Wes Anderson doing a James Bond spy
movie is sounds super super fun and
fresh and interesting tonight admit into
evidence Wes Anderson's pitch for a
dames Bond movie yes he gave an
interview about this I love that you
guys took this mess I wanted to do one
called mission deferred and my idea is
that this James Bond the Cold War is
over there's no gig he goes into CMMS on
the phone he's walking around her office
you know and finally says and in
parentheses uses hand gestures to say
he'll come back when M is off the phone
and you know the candy tree is like he
has a great coffee machine and maybe
gets a no bar fight or something cuz he
has a license to kill but there's
nothing to do movies are about
characters their movies are about
dialogue I agree there are some there's
some cool stylistic stuff in whiplash
it's a it's a well-directed movie it's
got a great climate interested in seeing
Giselle do a Bond action scene because
even just he does small moments of just
tension exploding really really well the
car hitting the kid when he's late late
for for-4 drum band for free for that
drum and start for the whiplash spoilers
i that does interest me if you guys
won't come on this wes anderson journey
with me then i you know i will go on the
the j I think lon in this you just took
this home the smart you took this the
safe answer here and as a human being
it's a lot more sensible answer
he's only ever gonna make my status ever
these bond fans don't want to see a Wes
Anderson movie they want to see a bomb
of it if you could bring those two
styles together it would make sense but
you can't didn't meet yourself you're
pointing to whiplash is the example but
it's like just about the clash of these
two characters that's not what bonding
on the moon that's his last solitary
it's still Neil Armstrong in the helmet
by him sighs personal fear of what he's
going through reboot of Moonraker to me
it's not just about the movies anymore
part of the fun about a Bond movie is is
the build who's gonna play bond who's
gonna be the lady who's gonna do the
song final thoughts please now we're
doing beyond those three questions now
is Alec Baldwin got an heir a bond I
don't know I think if you if you throw
in a whack and look I know Dan's not
gonna vote for me he's just over there
shaking his head at my crazy answer I
want to shake up the realm of Hollywood
Dan Merle look I just I just want
something new and weird and different
that's actually gonna interest me
instead of just like hey someone who
made a movie very similar to a Bond
movie also did good at that so we're
gonna have him do the thing that's why
just a left-field choice like Wes
Anderson I think could be really cool
bottle rocket is actually a very well
done heist movie it takes this sort of
twee and the look at all the hats out of
Wes Anderson so if you think that's all
he's capable of nope that's what he led
out the gate proving that he could do
something that didn't lean on all the
Rushmore stylisation I actually think
that he could do a Bond movie thank you
Joe
Wan rocket very tweet I would like to
put it still feels very much in line
with it with a Wes Anderson the thing
about McQuarrie is yeah he's done other
films that are sort of in this style but
he has not done a bond throw the Mission
Possible those are not exactly like bond
those are nothing
there's onra similarities but they're
not the same movie this'll be pimp is
not dr. people it's interesting to see
it's not folks the only genuine real
taste please send us some and still it
is so something new that would be
interesting for him to take on and and
both of these directors you just felt
like what I'm hearing a lot is it's just
it's apathy towards the bond films it's
like this is an uninteresting franchise
I want to bring in something that's
gonna change this whole franchise but
the Bond franchise doesn't need to be
reinvented it's been around for decades
it's been reinvented a ton of times it
already knows what it is and we just
want more good episodes the people who
like it just want a little bit of the
familiar with enough that's new to make
them feel like they've had a new
experience we we're already on like 6-7
Mission Impossible films clearly it's
not a problem for people that we keep
kind of revisiting similar ground but in
new ways with fresh takes different
kinds of action scenes and I think
that's exactly what McQuarrie would
bring to the franchise and it's a little
weird to argue that you know we want
something totally fresh we want
something totally new and then the
horror game that goes by it would be so
fun to see all of our Wes Anderson
favorites come back for another round
it's like what we want to see so I knew
we want to see something new so that's
why I think Chris macquaire is the
perfect marriage of bringing in so he
could do something fresh and interesting
but we still know that he could do what
makes a Bond film a Bond film thank you
on Spencer I'll keep it short cuz man
that was a lot that's a lot for a final
thought sorry
a final say the McQuarrie I don't think
he brings enough to the table even
though he is a good fit and I do think
the Wes Harrison brings a lot new wood
tail but he isn't a good fit
I think Damon's result brings both he is
a I would be excited more so than I what
about Danny what's-his-face boil boil
yeah and and I also think he could nail
the tone of it which again is style it's
an aesthetic that's James Bond more so
than anything else and he already has
experience in whiplash and in la-la land
of doing stories of about these cold
emotionally stunted men who are obsessed
with something and but really sad inside
but also will stop at nothing to get the
job done that's James Bond he's already
shown he can pull off those characters
I'm Amalia notches elf alright
ring-a-ding-ding that was a good fight
fellas dan Morelle
and roll that into your opinion on the
bout please so a couple facts Daniel
Craig only a producer on one bond fellas
the co-producer inspector none of the
other bond surprisingly have ever gotten
a producer role in their films Daniel
Craig's Bond movies just how many of
them were good while I'm sure a lot of
fans would speculate I would agree that
there's probably two that I like they're
all rated fresh and Rotten Tomatoes and
all the one of them have the audience
score in the fresh category as well so
you know no downright stinkers and their
critically Neil Armstrong did not go to
the moon alone he had two other people
with him interior not that he's by
himself I know that he didn't go to
people to crew that Tuesday no yeah I
don't want to know first man is going to
be a first person inside the helmet
accountable it's an emotional journey
not about the action we are on the sixth
Mission Impossible film sixth Mission
Impossible film the question was six or
seven yeah I think that Joe started
getting to the heart of his argument but
he did it in the closing and after he
already dropped out and endorsed one of
his competitors so I can't really give
it to Joe so it's between lon and
Spencer for me and I'm actually torn I
was I was really edging Spencer's way
but then I had a very very strong
closing however I think that lawns are
at closing argument really kind of dealt
with how Christopher McQuarrie could
take something similar and do something
in the same vein in a way and I like
Spencer's Pittsford a nice results work
the characters that he's that he has
portrayed the fact that he's done
character work with obsessed men who
wanting the job done and that that won
me over some goal was Spencer he was
very close between Lauda and Spencer
thank you Dan
yeah I like that point on behalf of
Spencer that the solitary men that
Giselle has told stories about but I
feel like that was too little too late I
feel like he kept hitting the style
style style and there wasn't as many
specifics regarding Giselle and I felt
like
kind of sat back and let everybody
cannibalize but it didn't serve you
because my in here quite enough even
though I like to the what you did say
didn't hear enough I really like I
thought Joe's answer was ridiculous but
then you really started to sell me on it
although I should have used that
solitary angry sad man argument because
that also applies for but Spencer at a
really better a damning quote but then
I've satin thought like what if like
Steve Buscemi played Batman or just like
something like you could just like doing
crazy stuff I really I don't know you
pitched a fun Wes Anderson story but
then what do I want from James Bond do I
want this one film that's gonna be an
outlier or do I want the nuts and bolts
and lawn hit some other great stuff like
the female leads in Kristen McQuarrie's
mi films have been really strong they're
been strong Nemus I and Jack Reacher and
usual suspects so at the end of the day
maybe a safe choice but I feel like I
just heard the most from lon
so it looks like we're tied up 1-1
Danielle please break this tie we'll see
what the people want and so the people
voted 46% for christopher mcquarrie 25%
for Damien Chazelle and 28% for Wes
Anderson 28 yeah
all right milan takes it any other ham
on this one right the Russos college
house key siblings the Mangold Kugler
the three biggest ones that I've seen
over and over and over again
knowin the lenovo and matthew vaughn the
first two said they did not want to do
it explicit right was my second choice
ik dan for me i don't do a good baldwin
will you just do a little narration of
like a bond getting an assignment for
narrating it well i have to start
everything because I've been doing angry
Alec Baldwin listen to me
she's got a hot girlfriend she fine I
don't know I don't know Joe I do I
promise to you I bring my facts
I respect up here all right so we were
locked up SPECT 1-1 lon and Spenny Joe
yet to get on the board but he's
delighted us all the way through so
question number three on a matusa us all
the way through searching is now playing
which characters computer would be the
best to spy on whose computer would we
want to just dive in there check the
search history go through files etc all
right
we'll start with player number three
question number three lon
there's a character from the second
Matrix film the architect
and I'll tell you why I want to look at
the architects computer because the
architect he's the designer of the
matrix is the controller of the matrix
if you look on his computer you're
seeing not just the contents of his
computer you're seeing the contents of
your very reality everything that has
ever happened everything that will ever
happen but not only that everything that
possibly could ever happen he could see
every sort of threat of time that could
lead to any eventualities so if you
could look on the architects of bitter
you would basically become a god you
would gain dominion over space-time in
reality you could see the results of
every decision you're gonna make
and how they would play out over time
the consequences of anything you could
do or you could just choose to look in
on little things insignificant things
you could sort of choose whatever you
wanted whatever level of omniscience and
omnipotence you want or about the world
around you you could see now the one
argument that I could see people taking
away from this is well but you're in the
matrix like this wouldn't work unless
you were inside the matrix which I say
great there's no reason to leave the
matrix especially if as cypher points
out in the first movie you can just take
a pill to forget that you knew about the
matrix that sounds great
anyone leave the matrix it's idiotic
stay in the matrix look at the
architects computer be the master of
your own destiny
alright red pills blue pills Thank You
lon background as human trader long hair
we're here if you ever just want to talk
[Laughter]
who cares about truth comfort is it I've
been doing a lot of weird stuff with
virtual reality lately yeah there's a
mystery that's played for me since the
late 80s and that is what's going on
with Polly's robot in Rocky he shows up
I'm a male coded robot as a gift for
rocky just given to him given to Paulie
not quite sure I guess it's Christmas
right it's his birthday birthday gives
him given the cake and paulie's clearly
displeased with it really not having it
the movie happens we cut back this is
this is scene one and then scene two of
this robot the robot is now a woman in
some sort of sexually charged
relationship with Paulie he says in
without a hint of sarcasm she loves me
so this is something where I think it
would add to the film or be like more of
a filling in the gap situation of
looking into this computer of this
coating is what was going on there what
happened why did an ex-boxer how did he
come into possession of this robot where
does it come from what is its purpose
what happened with Polly is this like
her where they fell in love and it was a
mutual thing or is this like ex machina
where it's doing like a Turing test to
see if it can escape I have so many
questions and I want to look into that
robot to find out all right the robot
from rocky for Joe oh look at Darth
Vader's computer
for a couple of reasons and behind me
padmé padmé in universe there's the
simple reason of if you can look at
Darth Vader's computer like the Empire's
dict like if if you can reveal the
secret that the Dark Lord of the Sith
that's just been choking fools left and
right is actually this little like sad
boy with a rat tail that just hates dirt
and sand and used to say the word wizard
like it was going out of style
like vampire screwed like there's
nothing Palpatine can do to bring the
world back from that if that information
goes out there on the on the net if you
sliced into Vader's a network and
discovered that like the episode so in
universe there's a function an important
function to see Vader's computer outside
of that I think at least think it'd be
funny to to get into Darth Vader's
internet search history and just this
this big scary guy and just see how like
he's googling and comparing different
like burned bombs and like comparing
prices on back to tanks you know because
he has to spend 90% of his life in one
and also let's not forget he is you know
a young boy in a rat tail who was very
upset and angry all of the time which
means there is so much just embarrassing
Padme poetry and weird live journaling
like there's so much to unpack there for
Darth Vader to just point and laugh at
and I just think that would be a real
good time hasn't Darth Vader suffered
enough have we not just to based this
once intimidating character you're
taking him down if he casts down any
more things than they already was after
the Pence's why are you just white can't
you wrap your head around just a guy
using something to come
necessarily will not be pretty but
computer he wants to have sex with it
like why am I gonna like now we risk
hacking into a robot to learn what is
her mission is it my choices in the
Commission did she's a birthday present
for him that's on the surface but then
why would a punch-drunk boxer get his
friend his ex trainer friend a robot
that he knows he would clearly hey
because rocky has unlimited finances at
that point and he's like hey I'm gonna
just go splurge the poly would
appreciate a sex pop anyone
the problem with the architect is like
there's too much there's - it's gonna be
dry and boring and in weird code well
beyond ones and zeros and I don't even
understand but an alien overlords
computer that's basic I speak I can read
that [ __ ] know what's on darth vader's
computer it's Death Star plans it's like
old Jedi the rogue one crew could have
survived if you just got on the computer
and you stole the tape so you wanna get
on so you want to do a prequel or you
wanna do people where they dock starfish
a leaked info to reasons why you spy on
a computer one your personal just
disgusting entertainment and to to bring
down a person in power now I'm going
with my knowledge about the universe and
everything you should do that's a whole
Pandora's Box it's like I don't want to
know why this weird old lonely
middle-aged guy would want to have a
girl robot in this house there's no way
Spencer can even start to broach the
secrets of the whole universe like
that's not a good transfer there's so
much there to just like pull apart and
make fun of it's like like the Dark Lord
of the Sith and he's and he's collecting
old podracing videos they know let's go
to some final thoughts lon Darth Vader's
computers from the 70s and it takes you
10 minutes to load it up there's barely
anything he can't even put an image file
on there and forget who you're even it's
gonna be similarly low-tech it's
probably like there's three things you
could program that robot - even - one of
them has turned into a green while in
love with in Windows 95 matrix is set in
the future it's a safety place of the
distant future where your technology as
we beyond what even we can imagine no
you're in the matrix it's always 1999
thank fine my finals all right around a
Spencer yeah look mine was strictly in
universe I wasn't thinking or out
universe sighing Unova miners thinking
or actually dunno which universe it's in
but the point is is that I think that
learning more about my robot will teach
us more about rocky for it feels like
there's a whole chunk missing from that
movie that looking into that robot's
files would tell us and I think it could
be interesting and I don't think we came
to any conclusive answers Joe's crude
one is is one but it's one of many
possible human sexuality Spencer yours
is kicking Darth Vader when he's down
that guy has a now that we know it's
anakin and have seen him say wizard and
now we don't need to see how pathetic he
truly is by going through his internet
search history if there even is an
Internet in Star Wars I'm not even sure
if there is there's a hole in it and
then the plot of a theoretical Star Wars
movie where they leak his info is just
that's just - James Gunn II for me
and yours yours is a what do you pick
again the architect like you could have
said it better here some open Pandora's
box what's the worst that can happen
it's truly a too much information you
don't want to have the entire world at
your fingertips cuz you're gonna end up
using it for evil let's be honest I just
I just feel like much like matrix to the
the vast sea of whatever it is it's on
the architects computer is gonna be just
incredibly dry and boring and I'm gonna
lose interest there's just no way to
sift through all that crap and analyze
it or do anything useful to it Spencer's
arguments against Darth Vader's computer
all rely on movie pitches and we're not
pitching a movie we're just pitching
whose computer we should spy on and I've
given a multitude of reasons why you
should spy computer one to bring down
his corrupt government - because it'll
be just the hilarious look to find out
that the Dark Lord of the Sith
definitely loved whatever version of new
metal there is coming out of the outer
rim metal is
new battle yeah fred durst is is torn
through the smaller cantinas right now
he's doing the hut circuit that's all it
is is just fascinating and fun to me a
Polly Polly has sex robots non-sexual we
don't need we don't I
Wow we do not know I mean maybe Dan
fact-checked whether or not Polly
consummated with the robot is there a
Rakhi fandom page there Dan
where are we factually where are we I
have nothing to add factually okay good
yeah thank you for that sure uh Wow yeah
three pretty different answers yeah so
uh yeah one word I think we're just over
shaming a sad old man look at that in
that robot yeah I don't know that wasn't
compelling enough for me on that one
Spencer and came down to Darth Vader and
lon and it's just it like you guys both
gave great arguments and it's basically
do want to go into this complex
characters weird search history or do we
want to just tear open the fabric of
existence yeah and oh crud I I think at
the at the end of the day yeah I'm gonna
go I I think Spencer had the ding on lon
and as much as it would make my brain
implode to just have beat would be so
overwhelming to go into the matrix and
that would not qualify for the question
best to spy on because it would give me
a aneurysm so I'm gonna go in like Darth
Vader I'm going with Darth Vader his sad
boy and I want
I want to see his Amazon wishlist the
bombs and the tanks and everything so
I'm going Darth Vader dan yeah I feel
like for me it was like what is of
interest here I feel like the Jo got to
the crux of what we would probably find
so for me it was between Joe and lon
and I really feel like I thought like
everything Joe pitched was like stuff we
already know I'd always needs bombs and
always a burn victim I know he likes pod
racing I know though even the plans is
just like well it's just an alternate
way to get to something that already
happened in the universe and Wow while I
do hear the the arguments about the
potential of unloading what you could
find it's also I think there's a great
amount to be had by knowing the fabric
of reality so I am actually gonna go
with a wand in this round all right you
want to know I don't know if I want to
know I don't know either but it's it's
it held more interest to me than then
doxing a daxing Vader late middle age
all right we are we're locked up at one
one Danielle can you shed some light on
this can you help us out the winner here
another overwhelming 60% really want to
see what an economy anakin is googling
you're super into it
I'm 33 percent wanted the architect and
then 6% I do just think it was asked and
answered
you'll see notable candidates basically
everyone Batman's ever known Batman out
for Lucius Fox
um the cerebro it was a really good one
and miles Grayson's computer from the
Terminator franchise oh yeah
Skynet now that robots have to kill you
right yeah now you've given a robot a
perfectly good reason
oh yeah you don't want to know that
information that's Skynet yeah get ready
for a terminator yeah your front door
okay so that means we're locked up at
one one one this is a great moment in
sports it's going to tie break alright
so the way the tiebreak works we're
gonna get three answers you'll argue it
out speed round style the first person
answer second person answer then third
person answer you'll go in that order
you'll each get 20 seconds and then
we'll go back around for 10 second
rebuttals and then we will pick Danielle
will give her own thoughts and opinions
now Danielle so we will pick whoever
will not move on we will let you know
who will not move on guy and whoever
whoever doesn't move on no hard feelings
cuz this was real well fought and
entertaining all the way around
gentlemen y'all ready I'm ready
Donna all right Tom here's a question we
already fought what was the worst movie
this summer now we want to know what was
the best movie of the summer I'll say
8th grade sorry to body
hereditary all right
eighth grade sorry to bother you an
hereditary lawn we heard from you first
will go lawn
Spencer and then Joe lawn 20 seconds
will begin when you speak we've had a
lot of great coming-of-age films
recently but what eighth grade does is
something really different it isn't just
a sort of a look at the process of
coming in it really puts you into the
perspective of this lead character who's
a much younger character than we're used
to seeing movies rooted entirely in
their perspective it's really innovative
it's really interesting it's an
amazingly performance from this young
actress and it's very insightful into
the process of growing up from the
inside start a bother you is a true
original there is no other movie like
this boots Riley delivered an original I
would argue masterpiece it's comedy it's
cutting satire it's visually so surreal
you can't believe what you're seeing
with your eyes and it makes its point in
in a backhanded way that really makes
you think and you it'll stick with you
long after you've seen it you won't
believe the twist you'll want to go
watch it again knowing that it's a movie
that stands up to repeat viewings
beautiful performances I think sorry to
bother you got in its own way by being
really pleased that it was the movie
sorry to bother you in a lot of ways
we've seen a lot of coming-of-age
stories eighth grade was a good one but
I've seen it the cool thing about
hereditary a horror movie should be
rooted in something strong and the fact
that it was rooted in this woman's
relationship with her mother this older
lady that's not something we see often
horror movies are usually and movies in
general they're usually younger folks 10
second rebuttals all the way around
again lon Spencer Joe long
so think about hereditary is that it
it's a horror movie it does be the human
emotional family relationships well it
just doesn't do the horror movie plot
very well and it's really leading that
by the wayside which is a ways that
happen movies like sorry to bother you
Charlie Kaufman movies
I was just stirred by hereditary I
wasn't scared eighth grade put me back
in a bad place didn't want to go back
there never want to go back to eighth
grade sorry to bother you is way
different than Charlie Kaufman turns up
and does have anything to say about
society they said to say about today
right now I think hereditary had a very
strong point of view that we don't see
from a lot of horror movies or just
summer fair in general I thought the
performances were incredibly strong the
monster and the sound were very iconic I
thought they stuck with you after you
left alright time
well fought and man and three movies I
really liked so I felt like when you
when you try to tingle on and on
eighth grade but that took you to a bad
place it was evocative that means it was
like kind of doing its job I think it
was part of it um great arguments all
around you argue sorry to bother you
real well man I feel like just Joe your
movie came up the most pedestrian of the
three for me so I'm sorry but Joe's
answer as third in my book Danielle um
so for this one I'm sorry I'm picking
the the one who'll know Avon's um I have
to say that the AIA is impressive as a
Tucker's talk about the perspective of
getting into the lead character and how
insightful it was in eighth grade I just
didn't feel like the there was a really
strong enough argument for that one so I
do have go with long all right
one one damn I think that counter to
what often happens in the speed round I
thought that everyone made against cases
very well for each pick but it came down
to the four cases for me and even though
he was arguing for the movie that would
have been my personal pick for the best
of the summer I'm gonna have to say that
I would advance Spencer and lon
and that Joe would be my pick - not all
right Joe I mean great work always fun
having you announcing hereditary Oh
well wowyou nightfalls do nice yeah
first of all you should really see I
would actually pick eighth grade as my
favorite film of the summer these are my
like grade in here and these are my
favorite movies of this era yeah but
yeah Jo super funny and thank you for
making me envision Wes Anderson
directing a James Bond movie privilege
enjoy yourselves if you just speed round
it is also why has one it is one want
the energy to talk that fast right now
oh yeah I'm calling it alright let's
throw down fellas
question number one of the speed round
mrs. Doubtfire is set to debut on
Broadway
yes well what other Robin Williams movie
should become a Broadway show good
question oh thank you you write the
questions you just kept it fair yes keep
it clean
Good Will Hunting did you say you said
show right yeah well it should become a
Broadway show
yeah okay okay Good Will Hunting I'll go
do Dead Poets Society Dead Poets Society
all right - great Robin Williams
performances Good Will Hunting versus
Dead Poets Society Spencer you spoke
first 20 seconds begins when you speak
now Good Will Hunting is a movie that
thrives on character on character growth
character development a small small
contained film and it really shines in
dialogue and playwrights have to have
amazing dialogue and Robin Williams
speeches in this movie and Ben Affleck
and Matt Damon the crackling dialogue
that carries you through this whole film
I think will really translate to the
stage it's not a movie that relies on
big physical grandstanding I just think
Good Will Hunting it's pretty expansive
it would be tough to sort of stage
there's a lot of locations there's a lot
of motion there's a it's a big sample
cast whereas Dead Poets Society it sort
of feels like it's mostly in that
classroom it's very sort of intimate
it's very kind of collective it's a few
sort of primary character
and I feel like that would really work
well in terms of staging out something
audiences really remember Good Will
Hunting
whereas Dead Poets Society it's an older
movie doesn't stick in the memory time
thank you for reminding people that
audiences really remember Good Will
Hunting and not your movie I don't think
you need to move around a lot you have
the car and you have the diner and you
have the classroom I think that you
could stage it actually really
interestingly and do cool things with
the streets of Boston
I mean poets in some ways it's a very
theatrical story it's about acting and
it's about being in the theatre and I
think that would resonate really well in
sort of the Broadway stage and sort of
everything that you could do in terms of
the stage craft of a play within a play
whoo all right Dan yeah Earl what do you
think there's an off-broadway version
that Poets Society starring Jason
Sudeikis judgment I decided I was not
aware I as a former techie in high
school I appreciated the fact that when
evaluating the Broadway show that lon
took not only the material does I feel
like you both argue the material very
well but the actual ability to stage the
show expense account and so I'm gonna go
on for thinking all around as to how it
could be staged well 100 lon
Danielle um yeah I do have to agree with
that I as as a former drama club
president and letterer in high school I
also appreciated and the ability to be
able to just send it the fact that he
brought up how it well it could be
staged and with how few characters I
just want all I see yes you're clearly
lon takes that one lon moves into the
lead to one by the way
I'm gonna I'm gonna brag that I was in
the chorus of South Pacific
yes okay question number two the speed
around Wesley Snipes is talking about a
possible blade for which movie would you
rather see of his blade for or
demolition man - hmm I'm gonna go
demolition man - I'll take blade for
okay lon spoke first for demolition man
- Spencer as blade for lon
20 seconds begins when you speak we've
seen three blade movies and part three
already kind of started around St we've
only been through the demolition man san
andreas universe once I want to see so
much more that's happening in that is
that or San Angeles excuse me not Santa
San Angeles we only see it one time on
screen there's so much more to explore
about that future society the world I
really want to follow up on that world
they'd see more of it you don't even
necessarily need to redo the same plot
just setting insanity you want to see
more of that world but those jokes are
played out they only work once they're
good in the 90s I want to see blade for
when he joins the MCU I want to see how
he plays with all these other Marvel
characters that have ascended the Marvel
Universe is missing something like blade
it's missing a hard-r vampire slaying a
total badass I think he's a he's a
missing element to the Avengers and Evan
they're all of a juice or whatever heat
blade does not integrate well into the
NCA we've already spent less the
Avengers are all getting together to
fight vampires blades basically useless
he's just like guy with his sword all of
his powers are if they're going up
against man lines he's got a sword he's
got a state gun he's got all kinds of
come food he would be great demolition
man - I don't want to see Stallone back
in that role and I don't think just uh
just Wesley on his own can carry a
sequel to that all right
Wow we yeah Spencer had the best
takedown of lawn and the best argument
for his movie Spencer gets it for me Dan
Spencer you had me at question number
three we are lined up at 2-2 if you just
map and then just like exhale the huge
fake flowers right of it okay nose blows
pods just the span of smoke trees okay
number three Disney's Star Wars land is
going to is gonna sell bows Star Wars
land so who would be the best Star Wars
character to get drunk with Lando
I'm gonna say Jabba the Hutt okay we
have Lando we have a job all right
Spencer whenever you're ready he's a
nice guy he's stylish he's always
surrounded by hot people interesting
people you can play cards you can kick
back in your cape room yeah you know you
play him right you're gonna win a
spaceship out of it he seems like a
really good hang he's got connections he
can introduce you to places he always
goes to the best bars knows the best
people and who wouldn't want to say
they're friends with Lando Calrissian
now we've always looked at hanging out
with Jabba the Hutt for the perspective
of people who are like his slaves or
he's got a party barge he's got a ton of
people Heather clearly this is a fun
time to get to watch max rebo play you
get to talk to salacious crumb it seems
really fun as long as people don't you
know come in and try to kill him but for
most of the time yeah it's all fun and
games until he starts choking his pay
his slave dancers it's a downer every
five minutes with Jabba he and all those
people are on his payroll you know those
people are not laughing at his jokes
they're just laughing cuz he's gonna
kill him otherwise
but the Lando a year later he soaks up
all the attention he's a terrible
wingman like Lando always has to be the
star the cool guy the center of
attention that's not fun to hang out
with you wanna hang out with Johnny so
it's been a party he's a cool guy I'm
all right Dan no man um
so as good of an argument terrible
wingman is I was already kind of there
when you mentioned him being a space
influencer
waiting for someone to mention that yes
you might go and you might watch him
straight-up kill a slave woman so yeah
I'd have to go with Lando yeah I'm also
going Lando because and you said we
don't know what happens but I'm thinking
it's gotta be fun I mean that's a
crapshoot we might get thrown into
you're getting a drink with it these
donkey does that tubular its prisoner
I'm gonna draw I'm gonna be drinking
with Lando
so Spenny is up three to two I would
like to note that the last people that
got drunk with Java got turned into vape
juice on his they exploded
yeah correct answer is wicked we got a
big old game point here Spencer gets it
he walks out of here the winner at lon
needs us to tie it up all right
question four of the speed round Jack
Ryan hits Amazon Prime this weekend
who's the better action Jack Ryan or
Reacher
Ryan I'll go Reacher okay Spencer you
have Jack Ryan
twenty seconds begins when you speak
Jack Ryan has an amazing cannon of
Airport novels written about in his diet
has done everything he's like your dad's
absolute wet dream of who he imagines he
is when he reads a book on it on a
cross-country flight and that's
translated into film John Krasinski's
actually done an admirable job as an
action star never thought I'd believe it
B does kick ass he's got so many
adventures to drop from it's actually an
on point in turns the airport I was
because Jack Reacher also has a very
successful line of his dad loved airport
novels so that's a that's an on point
overall look Jack Ryan it's like their
mediocre movies
he's like a desk guy it's sort of that
add that that's her fantasy fulfillment
job reach is a real badass action star
he's kicking ass for the very first
scene in his very first movie like he's
a which time no Jack Ryan like you said
yourself his fantasy fulfillment Jack
Reacher is like a third or fourth tier
Tom Cruise role you're looking at him
and you're just wishing you're watching
Ethan Hunt you're wishing you're
watching Top Gun you look at Jack
Reacher like
this isn't is best the question is who's
the better action jacket it's clearly
Jack Reacher because Jack was not really
an action that he's an analysis guy he's
like I'm gonna get on the horn with
Washington find out about this guy's
dossier Jack Reacher's an action guys
gonna get in there punch and get things
done time alright yeah nicely done
defending that point about the airport
novels a huge cadre of Jack Reacher
books and you really sold me long so I
go lon on that one Dan I would like to
point out that the Jack Reacher books I
loved by dads and non dad's alike yes I
share a residence with a very big fan of
the Jack Reacher books yeah but I
believe a long one hit the action beats
well and I think he knocked down Jack
Ryan well and I'm gonna go with with lon
as well with richer long
you just tied up the ballgame it's three
three years going since I'm just final
question speed round what a match it's
been thank you fellas for really
entertaining us the whole way through
here it is the winner takes the whole
game quiet place to is opening in 2020
which would you rather see prequel or
sequel
I'll go sequel ok prequel alright lon
answered first was sequel 20 seconds
begins when you speak long here's what I
really like to see for a quiet place to
I'd like to see another group of
survivors or another family and then
their unique sort of way of surviving
the attack and they meet up with the
main family that we met in the first
movie during the course of the action
sorta like I like called kind of walking
dead we do it we get different
perspectives on what's happening but we
still get to advance the story we don't
do that thing where we're endlessly like
redoing the origin like so many horror
franchise has it turned into they've
already talked about the quiet place
sequel and it's gonna take place with
the elites and how the elites are holed
up that's not as interesting to me I
want to see the prequel where it's
complete madness and it's more of like a
like a whether those zombie movies where
they're hordes and they're all running
or they're fast now
that's some piece that zombies I want to
see the fast some B's version of it
where they're all taking out hordes of
people and it's a different style of
action it's less quiet it's a it's not a
quiet place because people are getting
ripped apart all the time but the quiet
the use of sound that's what
this franchise supposed to every other
monsters are chasing people horror
franchise standout you don't want to
lose that you want to find it a way to
like reinvent it make you feel fresh
again but you feel like you could do
with a different group of survivors
don't get to go again I think you have
Mr yes you don't want to see the same
thing twice you want to see a different
flavor of this and you want to see
people how did other people come to the
realization how did the government fall
how did all these societies topple and
how did they make noise by mistake
Danielle first oh these were really well
argued this is really like I'm having a
not easy time I do have to say just by
the edge of the use of sound is what
makes this I have to go with lawn for
that because it is such a you know that
is the cornerstone not to say it's a
gimmick but that is a huge part of what
makes a quiet place a quiet place it
can't I would love to see things were
loud another or not but a loud place
okay lon you have the edge one Oh Dan
yeah by god it's like a tie because they
both did it so Wow yeah he's Spencer
kind of stumbled on it a little bit
so it's very close to me but I think I
have to go with lawn as well
you take my very first movie fight
victory damn I find that super
surprising because you're one of the
smartest movie minds around buddy
yeah and congratulations well fought all
the way through and it was no cakewalk
you earned it now go ahead and shout
some stuff out plug some stuff follow me
on twitter and l ons and i plug the news
you've heard about that right on lan
heiress thanks brother spencer you you
came in guns blazing on it and yeah
nicely played respect all around yeah
man anything you want to plug any
shoutouts uh if you made it this far in
the episode you know everything I'm
doing awesome Spencer always great to
have you Joe star
thank you for lighting us uh yeah
anything uh you want to favor us with
yeah Rowan recorded a four-minute comedy
thing about a Dalek that starts doing a
comedy for a living and it cost four
dollars and you should listen to it hi
it Dallas with my favorite robots no
because there's no living thing inside
they're just robots Dan Oh
before uh before we go to Dan with next
week I can't leave you guys without
plugging this it's our championship
match between that very man right there
Dan merle and our felted friend cucumber
and our champion the felted friend
cucumber had some words for tan merle
let's take a look we're perception
studio have two questions for you who do
you think you are what gives you the
right yeah you think you're gonna take
that belt from me no you can't take
cucumber on no way man that's why that's
why you sit with a laptop on the couch
with the peanut gallery yeah we don't
need no laptop it's all up here
and up here yeah yeah you go home you're
stupid Josh sure but Josh sure yeah yeah
your shirt might have teeth but your
arguments don't try try try try try to
do better than us do better than my man
kookaburra that's right you think it'll
beat us in that Josh don't hurt him
don't hurt him look and all that [ __ ] I
spit on his grave
I'll kill him so you can do that wow
they came after you hard dan any
response yeah you know cucumber earned
the right to fight me for the belt which
is he won that belt by winning a one
round fight against Mike Carlson and
he's got some pretty big talkin that's
pretty big talk for a guy that's been on
the show twice and has won exactly two
rounds because here's the thing if you
were talking about being being in the
peanut gallery
I built this peanut gallery so if you
want to come in here and talk smack I've
been on this show 46 times you barely
been on this show 46 minutes so if you
want to come in here and say that you're
gonna stomp on my grave and kick my butt
whatever you wanted this matchup and you
got this matchup but we're not living in
your world we're living in my world so I
can't wait to play you cucumber and I
can't wait to snatch that belt out of
your little felt hands and put it back
on my shoulder which is where it started
and where it belongs I'm looking forward
to next week okay murder Yeah right
that's gonna be a crazy one-on-one
matchup next week what this just in
dan and cucumber just threw some hot
sauce on that match we're throwing a
little bit more of a potent spice in
there one of our top contenders mr. ed
Grier is coming to the table and it will
be a three-way sham
ship match next yeah I mean I beat Edie
to get to the belt match so if he wants
to come back and have me beat him again
to win the belt is apparently an admirer
wait Dan is gonna put his hand right up
to come presents just like always I have
a height man as chunky as I don't know
yeah yeah sure dan you know very fine
hyping I went to an arts conservatory
thanks Dan Merle you earned it Edgar
want some cucumber want some so they're
gonna mix it up next week for the title
Daniel Radford thank you for holding it
down over there thank you as always and
thank all of you again it keep checking
the movie fights live hashtag because
people have been putting in some really
great theories and some long threads and
y'all put it a lot of work when you go
over there and so we appreciate it as
for me as per usual tights and fights
follow me on things I did just start a
patreon especially if you are someone
who enjoys the idea of hanging out with
me and talking wrestling in places look
and I'm not I don't have one of those
like a $100 tier menu I'll get $200 so
my tears are like very reasonable go
check it out and thank you all so much
my tears are all over my pillow
got everybody for watching I want to
give a shout out to my uncle Harvey
Thank You uncle Harvey they're always
being us for being such a great
supporter and watching everything I do
you are in the LA area this weekend come
by the UCB Franklin Saturday night 11:59
p.m. for the good boy of comedy Eric
Jennifer's a lot of fun there's gonna be
it's gonna be a super funny show at The
Upright Citizens Brigade theater this
Saturday September 1st at 11:59 p.m. and
otherwise I want to thank everybody here
I think Billy biz and jte for holding it
down and we'll see you next time
you